good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help them on your journey today's
message is pursue your passion over to
you kevin O'Leary me if you're
passionate and you're successful you'll
wake up you'll wake up one day rich you
won't really be going for the cash it
once happened to you everybody I talked
to this had success doesn't remember the
day they became a millionaire no idea
not important to them they remember
winning they remember building a
business of being successful again the
pursuit of freedom manifests itself in
passion that's really what it's about so
just the first draft of my next book I'm
super excited about it and basically
taking the top 500 rules I'm taking the
top 50 people that you guys have like
the fattest of my top ten rules times
they're ten rules do 500 rolls in
condensing them down to the most
consistent most common top and rules
that everybody has people come after
success and one of the ones that is
insistent it's the number one rule is
around college depression it was the
same that you love and this is not
something new on my channel see why gets
read as a tough test group this message
over and over and over and over again
passion follow my master passion follow
your passion
recognize your parachute passion passion
passion but it's a passionate passion
passion passion why do I care about this
one today is because it's coming from
Kevin under I count it on there you see
as the shark on Shark Tank and always
talked about money and his goals making
money in school decision on his soldiers
to go out and make more money and come
back and dream is to go to bed a little
richer
he was in the morning right that's all
he talks about on Shark Tank is multiple
interviews until different this one was
talking about pursuing your passion
this one was talking about in saying
that most people don't even remember the
day they became a millionaire because
they were doing something much more
important and I love giving that message
company because it's atypical from what
you normally hear from Kevin O'Leary but
it's true the money is important what is
important for everybody more important
for me I looked at my budgets and look
at my revenue but look at I caught a
look at what products are generating
sales and which ones aren't to look at
for this business
tes I look at what classes of generating
revenues which ones are how much we
could pay in which we could charge and
look at it constantly it's hard of
running the business if you are not
making money you're going to go out of
business the important thing though is
there has to be something more important
money money is number two must be number
three or four but it's not number one if
you're in business and money is number
one for you you're not going to have a
lot of success there has to be something
more important as passionately driving
forward whatever it is no judgment could
be almost things the thing that you
would do even if you're working cases do
what is it for me is helping
entrepreneurs I never thought I was
going to make money doing this and if
you look at a lot of successful
entrepreneurs they have no idea how
they're going to make money if you look
at Elon Musk you spot the real as a 90%
chance that this company failed but it
just needed to go try when I started
helping entrepreneurs and doing speeches
you know three people showed up to the
prerequisites crazy entrepreneurs don't
have money how am I going to ever turn
this into a business I still needed to
just do it because I loved it and even
if it never became a business I will do
it because I have to be passionate
helping entrepreneurs am i doing it over
and over and over again these sorts of
maneuver this is a trigger of ways I
could monetize it this is how it looks
like making money doing this money don't
talk money speeds everything money
husband I Ortiz one of those are the
buildings that money loans would have a
bigger impact but the number one goal
for me that's helping entrepreneurs so
excuse me I could spend all day helping
entrepreneurs not get hired on to go to
the bathroom and I have to eat because
me up so much on my crash at word might
be starving after birth I might be know
passed out afterwards but it's not as
each other pieces forward so you need to
find a thing in your businesses omits
the most important lesson that comes up
consistently across successful
entrepreneurs and athletes and musicians
as actors anybody who's reached the top
in the field you have to love what you
do and pursue your passion money is
important but it's not number one
so the bunch of a today is I'm curious
what is your number one what's the most
important things in your business
besides money to cure our death the
identity common I also want to give a
quick shout if you will hop it up I
believe I'll have those thank you so
much insignificance my books your one
words I really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you so continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love and I'll see you again far more day
for another sharp events better
[Music]
everybody around me their parents were
lawyers or investment bankers or
entrepreneurs or they were all laying
involved in business and that actually
didn't seem very much fun to me growing
up so I thought that being adults kind
of a drag
I actually was pretty depressed when I
graduated from college now literally
depressed for like six months I woke up
at one o'clock in the afternoon and laid
on a couch and looked up at the ceiling
to what I'm going to do and so with no
inspiration I just decided you know what
the only thing I can think of the do
right now it's going to make me happy is
if I go surfing as I planned a
five-month trip around Australia
Indonesia I living out of a backpack in
a van at the time if I didn't follow my
passion for surfing I would have never
had the idea for GoPro everything I did
I was following something I really cared
about something I loved something I was
passionate about and I kept following
that passion whether it was cars whether
it was anthropology whether it was art
photography and eventually it led me to
my huge passion my real passion which
was making movies which combined all of
those things and I realized that had I
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
I would have probably made
anthropological movies in New Guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
National Geographic and you know the
History Channel and been then making
features and I had done
Star Wars just the same if I'd have gone
into arts centre and become an
illustrator I would have probably
started doing animation and doing
animated films and making animated
things and then ultimately I would have
gone on and been right where I was so no
matter which route I took because I
cared about all of them they all led to
the same place had I done what my father
had wished me to do which is to go into
these office equipment business with him
which I knew labels that were going to
do I knew in a tin that my life would
have been unpleasant and so I think it's
very important not to do what your peers
think you should do not do what your
parents think you should do or your
teachers but to do with you inside or
even your culture things but do what's
inside you man what happened who pops
when he started a business
he failed what happened to mom and dad
they got a divorce what happened to us
we have six different places was it fun
hell no wasn't fun what happened in high
school to you did you play baseball did
you play high school basketball their
[ __ ] picked up for football your due
date to grow your life what was your GPA
what were you in high school what will
you have two words what makes you think
you're going to make it in life now you
got to stop selling the stuff to the sky
man stop it it's getting old go get that
job that you let's go up in you 12 bucks
an hour and part time get a degree stop
taking these damn risks we're not meant
to do something big with our lives
simple as that are we done I'm done I'm
good okay good
Pat I want you to know this voice is
never going away this voice is always
going to be there no matter how much
money you're going to make it's always
going to be there the great thing about
it is though every morning you wake up
you have a choice on which voice to
listen to but I want you to think about
a completely different thing right now
let's just say you're doing that thing
let's just say you'll buy into your
fears but you say you're buying to every
single thing you're worried about but
just say you don't make any decisions to
go after your dreams fast forward 10
years from that 20 years from that 30
years from that 40 years from now let's
just say your funerals around the corner
you have 50 people there 100 people
there maybe 200 people show up these
your friends family and people I love
you so you be left for one generation
remembered for two generations and
forgotten after that so truly the life
you want to live is that really what you
want to do I don't know if that's the
life you really want to live you see
what I've noticed is no matter what you
ever do you'll have a lot of lonely
times you can lie to your family you can
lie to your friends you can fold the
world into realizing that why you didn't
win was because some challenge that you
had to face but there's one person you
can never like to that is the man in the
mirror
you can never lie to the man in the
mirror never but a rest of your life the
man in the mirror is going to look back
at you and say you did not choose to go
after your dreams and you have to be
okay with that now what I would like to
encourage you to do is to make the right
choice I encourage you to face your
fears and pursue your dreams go pursue
the dreams them out of the most to you
you got one shot at this thing here and
if it works out and it's going to feel
so good for you if it doesn't and you
can't the courage to make that decision
you make the right choice trust you will